كل الطرق تؤدي الى الصين جوا وبرا وبحرا
فلا بوابات مقصده ولا حجرا صحيا مطلوبا
لقد قررت البلاد انهاء عزلتها والانفتاح
مجددا على العالم بعد 30 سنوات من القيود
الصارمه والمرهقه لمجابهه جائحه كورونا
انا متحمس ثلاث سنوات منذ عوده الى الوطن
الام اخر مره بسبب كوفي 19
في المطارات اختفت الحواجز التي كانت تفصل
بين الرحلات الدوليه والداخليه وتخلى
الموظفون عن بالذاتهم الواقيه التي
لازمتهم منذ فرد سياسه صفر كوميدي
رفعت معظم القيود المفروضه عند الحدود بين
بر الصين الرئيسي وهم كونغ وسمح لنحو
60,000 شخص بالسفر في الاتجاهين يوميا مع
اقتراب حلول العام القمري الجديد
صباحا استقبلت تشانغهاي وهي اكبر مدينه في
الصين اول رحله طيران الدوليه قادمه من
نيوزيلندا لا يتوجب على القادمين اليوم
سوى اظهار رمز يثبت انهم سجلوا اختبار
كوبيه 19 سلبيا في غضول 48 ساعه قبل
المغادره مطار العاصمه الدوليه الرئيسي في
بيجين وصلته الاحد ثمان رحلات خارجيه
وينتظر ان يستقبل المزيد بعد ارتفاع
الحجوزات منذ اعلان السلطات الصينيه الشهر
الماضي فجاه الغاء معظم القيود قرار رفع
القيود وهو استداره هائله في سياسه الصين
الوبائيه تخطى اعتباراته الصحيه الى ابعاد
اجتماعيه باعتباره اذانا بلم شمل بعض
الاسر والاحبه بعد افتراق دام ثلاثه اعوام
والقرار ايضا محاوله للتعافي الاقتصادي
بعد سنوات الاغلاق والعسله
اعتقد انها خطوه ضروريه لقد اصبحت في
الطبيعيين الان وبعد هذه العقبه سيكون كل
شيء سلسا
لكن الخطوه تواجه عقبات كثيره بينها موجه
اصابات جديده متفاقمه ادت الى وفايات
واقتراض المستشفيات لا سيما في المدن
الكبرى وهو ما دفع عددا من دول العالم الى
وضع قيود على سفر الصينيين اليها بذريعه
تكتم بجينا على حقيقه المشهد الوبائي
الراهن في اكبر بلد في العالم من حيث عدد
السكان
واول بكره لظهور فايروس